hello and welcome to the newshour
israeli police have fired stun grenades
to disperse protesters gathered outside
a police station in west jerusalem
a news conference was underway calling
for the release of detained palestinians
when it happened
so it comes after resident monal kurd
was taken from her home in
occupied east jerusalem on sunday she's
one of the people in the neighborhood
that israel is trying to forcibly remove
they want to remove us from jerusalem
they do not want us to live here at all
we are here we are staying in our
country the journalists are here and
they are recording us
the weapons of the palestinians are the
camera and the words whereas the israeli
army is heavily armed
that's the difference so that happened
just a little while ago let's bring in
she's joining us from occupied east
jerusalem what more can you tell us
about the kurd siblings detention
and the charges against both muna and
muhammad
well we just heard a few minutes ago
mona has been released
she has emerged from that police station
we still don't know
if her twin brother muhammad
is also released or will be released
shortly now it's really not clear what
the charges
are so far uh we'll have to hear from
her what happened
inside but in general uh earlier the
police said that it was some sort or
rather sorry the lawyer told us that
she was accused of inciting public
unrest which really is a
big umbrella term uh that could mean
anything
at this point so i'm pretty sure that
mona will be giving some sort of
statement
uh very very soon she is very active on
social media she has been
documenting day in day out what goes on
in sheikh jarrah
and it's probably because of that that
she has been detained this morning
and what is happening in the
neighborhood of itself right
at the now it's very calm uh we were
there earlier today
but it is a flash point there is a lot
of tension
there that's been going on for weeks
really and many people would actually
tell you
especially palestinians that it is
really those tensions
that snowballed into eventually
that 11-day war on gaza now you have
those families
who are threatened by evictions they are
waiting to hear
from the uh from israel's attorney
general on june 8th
uh what is his reasoning in all of this
whether these
forceful evictions were going to go
ahead
or not but they have really become to
symbolize
and muna specifically uh really the
plight of
many other families around occupied east
jerusalem who face
exactly the same fate this kind of
forceful eviction from their home and i
have to say they're not giving
and substitute housing they're just told
that they have to leave
the house now um these tensions are
likely to continue until their
their fate is not is not clear
uh so and mona i think was really
disturbing
or the authorities israeli authorities
because she has been so vocal about it
she has been filming
every day what goes on on a daily basis
the friction between
for example her family or other families
and the jewish settlers
who have moved in her same street i have
to tell you that
on the on the elkhorn family property
there is
another separate building a small house
and that house has been already taken
uh by a jewish settler so mona more than
anyone
knows exactly what are those kind of
tensions and that's why she has been so
vocal
okay huda thank you so much for that
update from occupied east jerusalem